[Music]
all right this weekend the fakin well
slowly deteriorating New York Times
published a confidential memo from
president Trump's attorneys to the
office of the Special Counsel now if
leaked by someone on Muller's team this
is a huge criminal breach of trust Mayor
Giuliani thinks that's a fact now but
while neither the left nor the
mainstream media seem to care about why
a confidential letter was leaked from
Robert Muller's office to the press many
liberals and how feigning their
predictable moral outrage over the memos
contents especially this paragraph that
details the legal team's view of
obstruction and the president's power to
pardon quote the president's actions
here by virtue of his position as the
chief law enforcement officer could
neither constitutionally nor legally
constituted obstruction because that
would amount to him obstructing himself
and that he could if he wished terminate
the inquiry or even exercise the power
to pardon if he so desired
now this echoes exactly what attorney
after attorney after attorney have been
telling you right here on this program
now for months and as president Donald
Trump at his legal team they do have the
power to literally order the Department
of Justice to actually initiate an
investigation and an investigation and
by the way for any reason that is within
the president's constitutional authority
even the DOJ admits they can't charge a
sitting president with obstruction so
why are we talking about it now also the
president's power to pardon even himself
it is an absolute power and over the
weekend look at that guy there you see
him well here's a little grayer now but
that's Clinton sycophant turned
so-called journalist for ABC News
Georgie Stephanopoulos now you can see
him there whispering in Bill Clinton's
ears well yesterday Stephanopoulos he
asked Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump's
attorney former New York City Mayor what
is a completely nonsensical totally
hypothetical and frankly ridiculous
question about this very concept it is
irrelevant to everything in the reality
that is happening
take a look do
and the president's attorneys believe
the president has the power to pardon
himself he probably is not but he
probably does he has no intention of
pardoning himself but he probably
doesn't say can't I mean that is another
issue really interesting constitutional
argument can the president pardon
himself run the partner knee it would be
an open question I think it would
probably get answered by gosh that's
what the Constitution says and if you
want to change it change it but yeah a
lot of focus on the president I think
the political ramifications of that
would be tough pardoning other people is
one thing pardoning yourself is another
Rudy Giuliani was kind of laughing about
it well he does have the power but
that's not gonna happen and look at how
the media's reacted and little Georgie
Stephanopoulos acts all bewildered this
is not a new concept we'll take you back
let's go down memory lane 2016 then
candidate Hillary Clinton remember hot
water over a gross blatant misuse of
classified information on the
mom-and-pop bathroom closet server
well many were actually arguing thinking
that she was going to be elected
president that she if she was could
rightfully pardon herself let's look at
this headline from Dan Abrams law and
crime website if Hillary Clinton is
indicted while President Clinton could
pardon herself and Congress might be
helpless and this article from The Wall
Street Journal quote the short answer to
whether the Constitution permits all
pardoning is yes it probably does that
seems to be the prevailing but by no
means unanimous opinion among legal
experts now of course that ridiculous
question to Giuliani came from the same
guy who made a name for himself as being
Bill Clinton's political hitman dorias
run for the president this is now the
spokesman and news person for ABC News
he's no Peter Jennings take a look what
his name suggests I can send you a fax
with names addresses phone numbers of
who you had an affair with it wouldn't
make it true
it is completely if you went on the
radio and said that little Clinton is
the father of illegitimate black child
you would be laughed at
you would think you're crazy I guarantee
you that if you do this
you'll never work in democratic politics
again maybe you don't want to I'm not
saying it matters you will be
embarrassed before the national press
corps people will think nobody will
believe you and people will think you're
scummy
Oh George looks so fair and unbiased he
seems like a real journalist in that
video now meanwhile Rudy Giuliani's
comments were clearly based on legal
precedent and earlier today the
president himself backed up his legal
counsel he tweeted out quote as has been
stated by numerous legal scholars I have
the absolute right to pardon myself but
why would I do that when I've done
nothing wrong
which brings us to a very important
point this phony feigned so-called
outrage from the left and the media and
other anti Trump groupies is over
something that has not happened and
something that will not happen because
President Trump Trump has done nothing
wrong and it was a hypothetical that
Rudy Giuliani was actually laughing at
still the media's echo chamber blowing
up over something rooted in legal
precedent backed up by real
constitutional scholars and yet
something that has not ever happened and
probably won't take a look at the media
once again making much ado about
absolutely nothing and watch this you
know knowing this is the same media as
you watch this totally missing in action
on the biggest story in their lifetimes
which is the largest biggest abuse of
power corruption scandal in US history
they don't talk about that this is what
they focus on a stunning statement here
probably from the president openly
declaring that he believes he is above
the law try to picture an ordinary
criminal who committed a crime saying
that I can do whatever I want and by the
way I'll pardon myself you sound like
you're guilty when you say think about
what we're talking about the president
all morning is basically again saying
the President of the United States is
above the law and is not required to
comply with the Constitution or the laws
of the United States I mean that is
staggering they are kidding themselves
and will be let down horribly if they
ever decide to try this on to take this
and put wheels on this and take it out
for a spin to the United States Supreme
Court if you don't believe me
go to the Supreme Court you may get one
you may get two votes that's it
you will be run over the president of
United States is talking about pardoning
himself about not being indicted you
have to look at what the political
environment would be what what political
environment would be created by that
we're really talking about the end of
his presidency if you're talking about
the president United States saying I'm
going to pardon myself even if
Republicans try to protect him you're
talking about the collapse in many ways
of the institutions of this Republic
another week more hysteria more feigned
moral outrage another fake scandal push
from the same people that have been
wrong for a year and a half and they yet
want you to trust them no wonder their
approval ratings are in the gutter
almost at single digits and journalism
in this country is dead and buried also
tonight we have more evidence your deep
state is crumbling right before our eyes
look at this CBS News poll Americans
yeah they've lost confidence in Robert
Moniz probe or so-called probe they
agree with President Trump the
witch-hunt needs to end michael barone
now writing quote Obama's spying scandal
- starting to look a lot like Watergate
I keep telling you it's Watergate on
steroids
former Attorney General Michael Mukasey
smart man dressing down one former deep
state operative at the center of all of
this look at what he says about Brennan
take a look John Brennan is gonna have a
lot to answer for when this is over
because his participation in for the
participation of the CIA in have been in
providing an informant to be used in
connection with the mauler investigation
I think is a story that hasn't yet been
told the guy was the informant you know
was it was a CIA asset not an FBI asset
I would like to know how a CIA asset
suddenly becomes an FBI informant who
organized that who paid him and was John
Brennan running some kind of
multi-agency operation relating to
the the the Trump campaign I don't know
that he has any credentials as a mind
reader or as a psychoanalyst to be
analyzing the president's motives but
his own performance is certainly nothing
nothing to write home about and new
developments tonight surrounding the
ongoing obstruction from the Department
of Justice this is a sad moment in
American history now the house Intel
Committee Chairman Devon Nunez gave an
update on the DOJ stonewalling he had
some really strong words for his
colleague in specialy House Oversight
Committee chairman trey Gowdy who was so
dead wrong last week unfortunately and
he didn't even have all the information
that he needed before he made these
comments now take a look at what he said
to our friend Maria Bartiromo we should
have been provided all of this
information that we've been asking for
over and over and over again we issued a
new subpoena and so now we've been
waiting we that we've attended two
briefings they were very small briefings
not a lot of information but we were
happy it was progress we believe that
there are some documents information
that we will review this week what I
would say is if you don't have any to
anything to hide the Deputy Attorney
General knows that mr. Gowdy would love
to exonerate the Department of Justice
and the FBI and we got to be very
careful because the medias tried to make
a bigger deal about this and what it is
what trey Gowdy is specifically talking
about is this small slice of the
investigation that we're looking at as
it relates to whether or not informants
an informant or informants were used
that's what he's referring to when he
talks about that the president's not a
target of this investigation I believe
that mr. Gowdy knows very well and he's
been instrumental in helping us get to
the bottom of the FISA abuse that that
did occur we have more updates on the
swamp each night as we peel back the
layers of that onion of the deep state
and dismantle it and we're doing it
night by night brick by brick all right
we have to turn our attention believe it
or not the former President Bill Clinton
back in the news like an unwanted
houseguest that overstate is welcomed by
let's say a few decades Bill Clinton is
back in the public spotlight obviously
making money pushing a brand new book
and it's off to a horrible start so what
the grandfather we can say we can call
on the grandfather of today's
to movement Clinton failed to realize is
that it's no longer 1996
and all his buddies in the mainstream
media can no longer afford to give him
the free pass on his history of rampant
horrific sexual misconduct during an
interview with NBC News the former
president was finally pressed and they
could have done this before the election
but of course they wanted Hillary to win
but he was pressed on how he mishandled
the Monica Lewinsky scandal and almost
unbelievably Clinton who was impeach for
lying under oath said he did the right
thing remember Paula Jones said he
dropped his pants and got naked in front
of her we know what Juanita brought were
charged him with rape Kathleen Willey
groping Graham big fondling touching
against her will in the Oval Office and
then of course Monica watch this Clinton
says critics are now pouncing in light
of the me2 movement but he stands by his
decision to fight impeachment rather
than resign so a lot of the facts have
been conveniently omitted to make the
story work but I think partly because
they're frustrated that they got all
these serious allegations against the
current occupant of the Oval Office and
his voters don't seem to care I think I
did the right thing and defended the
Constitution yeah what fact was omitted
please tell us because let's see you
lost your law license you lost the
judgment in the case of Paul Jones and
paid money and yeah you were impeached
finally you got to give some credit to
the mainstream media well they obviously
lost sight of what their usual biases in
this case it was NBC Craig Melvin
continue to press Clinton and the former
president just could not take it handle
it or even believe it he's living back
in 1996 take a look do you think
differently or feel more responsibility
no I felt terrible then and I came to
grips with it did you ever apologize and
know yes and nobody believes that I got
out of that for free I left the White
House 16 million dollars in debt but you
typically have ignored
beeping facts in describing this and I
bet you don't even know them didn't feel
I thought it were an Apollo I do III I
do know I've never talked to her but I
did say publicly on more than one
occasion that I was sorry I dealt with
it 20 years ago
+ and the American people two-thirds of
them stayed with me and I've tried to do
a good job since then with my life and
with my work that's all I have to say to
you what everyone said we were alone I
never really thought we were alone me
and Monica you know I looked out the
window as a girl in a bicycle so long as
somebody else out there in the world
you're never really alone
are you I have sex with that woman not a
single time for years both Bill and
Hillary Clinton they've acted above the
law the complicit me T gave them a pass
they ignored all of this in the 2016
election and Bill Clinton's sick
perverted history of sexual misconduct
including all of these allegations we've
interviewed these women even rape have
gone unpunished and the media didn't
bring it up in 2016 because they wanted
her elected and by the way we all know
Hillary was gifted leniency by James
Comey after she committed felonies
violated the Espionage Act deleted
33,000 subpoenaed emails acid-washed our
hard drive and broke up her devices with
a hammer or had an aide do it do you
think you or any other ordinary everyday
American would be given a pass by law
enforcement if you did what Hillary
Clinton did or did what Bill Clinton did
I doubt it and what about the Clinton
campaign paying a foreign spy to cook up
unverified untrue proven false in most
cases Russian intelligence how to use as
an OP research against President Trump
anyone in the Clinton campaign under
investigation for that Russian collusion
no the mullah witch hunt is only
investigating Trump associates we have a
two-tiered justice system this is the
danger in this country today if we're
going to remain a constitutional
republic one that benefits the Clinton
at every turn and they have laughed all
the way to the bank and by the way you
should all be outraged now despite all
of this we do have amazing news to share
with you tonight it is now the 500 days
since Donald Trump
was inaugurated and after months of
predictions that a trump presidency
would lead this country in ruins well is
now undeniable that the entire world is
seeing massive serious progress under
the president's leadership we have
pending talks with the North Korean
dictator that's just days away we're
going to talk about the denuclearization
of the Korean Peninsula that now weighs
in the balance in the interim let's see
Kim jong-un has halted all of his
missile tests no more missiles being
fired over Japan in the interim he
literally is destroying one of his
nuclear test sites it's been disabled
don't forget three American hostages
were also returned and he walked over
the DMC into the arms of the South
Korean president all good news not a
dime paid like in the case of Obama or
Clinton and showing peace through
strength works and also breaking today
three longtime North Korean generals
have been fired by Kim jong-un another
good potential sign of North Korea's
commitment toward serious reform and
meanwhile on day 500 the trump president
seen let's see we've seen so many great
developments right here at home we don't
even have the time to list them look at
the side of your screen nearly three
million plus jobs have been created
300,000 and manufacturing alone the
unemployment rate and almost
unprecedented 3.8 percent the lowest in
50 years American we we have four
african-americans all-time low
unemployment rate same with Hispanic
Americans same for women in the
workplace 14 state record lows as
relates to unemployment consumer
confidence 17-year high now this after
passing a historic 3.7 trillion dollar
tax cut and cutting 22 regulations for
every new one enacted and even the New
York Times of all places writing we ran
out of words to describe how good these
job numbers are and fake news see and
then even had to report that the
unemployment rate matches its lowest
point in half a century
other accomplishments include the
president keeping his promise the u.s.
embassy has moved to Jerusalem in Israel
getting America out of that horrific
Iranian nuclear deal and you can't
forget about Trump's actions against
Assad Isis and Vladimir Putin and you
likely won't hear about this
in the press but the construction of
that wall on the southern border of this
country yeah it started in San Diego and
remember successful the accept the
successful appointment of Neel Gore such
an originalist to the Supreme Court as
promised I could go on and on it'll take
up the whole show look at Zogby more
Americans now believe they're much
better off then when Donald Trump took
office but yet the elites in this
country the Democrats the media
Hollywood and others all warning you
that President Trump would be bad for
America you knew better bad for the
world you knew better in fact these
people were actively and are actively
rooting for the president in the country
to fail so they can get power back what
they don't understand is that Americans
are fed up with both parties they're
disgusted
so they purposefully elected an
iconoclast a disrupter and that someone
that they knew would get results and
make decisions and move at the speed of
Trump and in his first 500 days the
president he has proved his naysayers
wrong so tonight an important question
to ask who do you trust the anti Trump
sycophants who have been wrong over and
over and over again actively now in the
position of having to root for failure
of the president that means failure for
the country and by the way a guy that
has gotten results tonight the answer to
this question is clear everyone in
America is reaping the rewards you the
American people made the right decision